[музика]
чому Україна вимагає від Заходу надання
літаків винищувачів
як приміром президент України Володимир
Зеленський у виступі перед членами
британського парламенту В Лондоні
протягом останнього року Україна
регулярно зазнавала атак з повітря
російськими винищувачами з ракетами типу
повітря земля незначні Українські
військово-повітряні сили які ще
збереглися майже нічого не можуть
протиставити російським винищувачам каже
Юрій Ігнат речник повітряних сил ЗСУ
стан зрозуміло що важкий стан Чому Тому
що літак наймолодший який момент на
озброєння це літак
1991 року літак су-27 наші літаки які ми
маємо на озброєнні експлуатуємо досі
вони вдвічі старші вже за своїх пілотів
і вони літають на лінії фронту на півдні
та сході України з максимальними ризиком
бути збитими
[музика]
Україна має застарілі винищувачі
радянського виробництва мік-29 скільки
саме Україна не розголошує
тим часом російські нападники мають
сучасну проти повітряну оборону
а технології так на дві голови вище
скажемо так він бачить нашу найнищувач
російські там сути це 35 бачать вдвічі
далі І городар він має системи захисту
він ракету може випустити теж вдвічі
далі ніж наш наш Пілот навіть не бачить
коли по ньому випущено ракет тобто
тільки можна донести йому інформацію
засобу на радіозв'язку тобто сказати що
по тобі працюють щоб він колись ракета
наближається тоді він може до нього дуже
ну менше часу зреагувати
російські винищувачі натомість ведуть
вогонь з безпечної відстані часто З неба
на Чорним морем здійснюючи ракетні
обстріли і по українському цивільному
населенню ворожі літаки злітають і
приземляються з російських аеропортів
або занексованого Росією Кримського
півострова багато техніки зокрема
зосереджено довкола кордонів наших на 40
летовищах було більше 700 літаків та
вертольотів різних типів на тих 40 для
того щоб які використовує Росія проти
України своїх Атака цей Білорусь і
окупований Крим також території Росії
український військово-повітряні сили
просять до 200 західних винищувачів
Франція не виключила поставок своїх
літаків Рафал які будуються ще з
1990-х років це найдорожчий винищувач
також обговорюється можливість надання
сучасних літаків gripple зі Швеції
щоправда їх не так багато
єврофайтер також регулярно опиняється у
центрі дискусії але найбільш
реалістичними військові аналітики
вважають поставки винищувача НАТО f-16
країни що підтримують Україну мають
понад 2000 літаків цього типу
експерт з питань України Мюнхенської
конференції з безпеки ніколанги вважаю
що f16 найшвидше Міг би допомогти
Україні
Ми бачили сигнали Віта Нідерландів щодо
винищувачів f16 Я думаю що в 16 дуже
цікаво з точки зору України літак тому
що багато країн мають такі літаки це
багатоцільовий літак можна
використовувати для виконання багатьох
завдань гадаю він добре підійшов би для
України і українські пілоти могли б
навчитися керувати цим літаком у розумні
строки на думку більшості західних
аналітиків Це єдиний спосіб яким Україна
має Хоч якийсь шанс протистояти
російській перевазі у військовій техніці
та солдатах на фронті російські війська
міцно копалися вздовж 1200 кілометрового
фронту захищені російською
протиповітряної оборонною Стелу
Річ у тім що наразі Росія пристосувалася
до відстані досяжності України особливо
на півдні дає відносно невелика смуга
окупована Росією дрф утримує цінні
об'єкти управління контролю та
логістичної інфраструктури поза межами
досяжності України
і звичайно Україна потребує більшого
охоплення Що підготувати поле бою для
наступу щоб звільнити цю територію
це дозволило б Україні російські ракетні
позиції на лінію фронту і підготувати
територію для визвольних атак на землі
Українські військово-повітряні сили вже
готуються до прийому західних
винищувачів f16
смуги з бетонним покриттям не плити
аеродром який плюс у Великобританії вже
розпочалося навчання українських пілотів
на західних літаках пілотування
кілька тижнів вони живуть літати без
проблем але
навчитися застосовуватися всі типи
озброєння працювати у складі підрозділів
ланка пара ескадрилья завдавати ударів
по повітряних іноземних цілях це
потрібно на цей час місце або в умовах
війни це теж Важко Україна сподівається
що її пілоти і наземний персонал зможуть
використовувати західні винищувачі f16
щонайпізніше через шість місяців у
комбінованому бою із сухопутними
військами аби звільнити наступні
окуповані Росією території
Ukraine
Україна має заздалегідь планувати
подальший перебіг війни і Якщо зараз
нагальним питанням є інтеграція
механізованих сил і збільшення
боєприпасів Я думаю що в
середньостроковій перспективі коли ми
думаємо про звільнення країни від
російської окупації наземні війська
потребують підтримки з повітря
саме тому Україна вимагає від Заходу
сучасних винищувачів таких яке в 16